la menace ne sera pas mise à exécution
en tout cas pas immédiatement le maire
de montfermeil qui voulait couper les
crédits à deux écoles maternelles ayant
accueilli contre sa volonté des enfants
d'immigrés est revenu hier sur sa
décision
les deux écoles pourront donc
fonctionner normalement à compter du 6
novembre prochain mais peut-être pour
deux mois seulement
je ne suis pas revenu sur la décision je
n'ai fait qu'un report dans le temps
pierre bernard ne désarment pas la
décision prise par le maire ces derniers
jours reste donc d'actualité
seul élément nouveau elle ne sera pas
appliqué le 6 novembre prochain date de
la rentrée scolaire sursis ou ultimatum
quoi qu'il en soit pierre bernard a
donné deux mois aux pouvoirs publics
avant d'appliquer ces mesures couper les
moyens de fonctionnement les deux
maternelles où sont inscrits contre le
gré du maire des enfants immigrés
ensuite l'exclusion des directrices des
établissements concernés
entre le 6 novembre 89 et le 6 janvier
90 ont été si la situation sera vraiment
très différentes
en tout cas pierre bernard sort
maintenant du terrain scolaire il n'y a
pas de problèmes scolaires
non le problème sans problème
d'immigration il faut bien réunion de la
même chose montfermeil c'est un problème
d'immigration et là dessus je tiens fort
et ferme sur les prix je ne serai pas et
les prix sont élevés le maire exige de
nouveau dans une lettre adressée au
préfet l'arrêt immédiat de toute
attribution de logements aux étrangers
avec consultation préalable de la
municipalité principalement dans la cité
des bosquets de montfermeil
le préfet de seine saint denis répond
que la rénovation de ce quartier est une
priorité que les décisions seraient
prises prochainement peut-être un
embryon de solution